hi everybody
you guys! Look, first of all this is a show about dreams comming true
And the fact that I´m up here is a dream comming true
Because all fans yells so much about this show there should be a restriction order
on me
I don´t wanna waste any time so let´s just get started
I´m Yvette Nicole Brown, by the way thank you for comming
I wanna bring out this wonderful cast and the creators
So first we are gonna start out with Edward Kitsis and Adam Horowitz
who created this wonderful universe
you sit down there
Everybody has to find their names
up next is someonethat gave me my own personal charm attack
this morning
Josh Dallas who plays charming
Up next is the fabulous and beautiful Emma Swan, Jennifer Morrison
And the lovely man that has Emma in the palm of his hand
Hook, Colin O'Donoghue
And then we have the heart of Storybrooke
Jared Gilmore who plays Henry
We have de gorgeus and *** Evil Queen/Regina, Lana Parrilla
We have the beautiful and wisdom Belle played by Emilie de Ravin